[Music]
on this remembrance day crowds return in
the nation's capital to reflect and pay
their respects we're just so
fortunate and blessed to be here the
gratitude the grief and what delayed the
ceremony
europe's stranded migrants
the escalating crisis and the new threat
from the president of belarus
the murder trial gripping america
as the judge lashes out come on
plus an indigenous veterans service and
sacrifice he returned a decorated
military hero he served with distinction
so why was he denied the recognition he
deserved
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
across this country canadians remember
the courage service and sacrifice
of the men and women who lost their
lives while serving in the military
remembrance day ceremonies usually take
place with military precision but in
ottawa today at the national war
memorial a security issue disrupted
things the prime minister and his wife
sophie gregoire trudeau arrived about 15
minutes late the other dignitaries
including the silver cross mother and
the governor general were also delayed
that meant the two minutes of silence
always observed at exactly 11 a.m was
delayed too
the rcmp later said a suspicious package
was spotted in the vicinity of the
ceremony they say as a precaution it was
investigated and the dignitaries were
held back until the package was clear
there was another ceremony in ottawa
today too one that gets less attention
it's held at the national aboriginal
veterans monument mike lacature begins
our coverage tonight
[Music]
the somber notes of the last post an
enduring ritual of remembrance the
pandemic paused large events last year
but fewer restrictions now meant more
people could gather at the national war
memorial
[Applause]
barb sutherland has waited seven years
to make the 12-hour drive to ottawa for
this moment and this feeling how so very
fortunate i am to be standing
here while so many others weren't able
to
and gave us this freedom that we have
today
a lesson not lost on nine-year-old
dimitri lauren who was here with his
mother to remember
the people that died in the war
[Music]
that same sentiment is felt by a group
of indigenous veterans who every year
hours before the national ceremony hold
their own solemn reflection at a
monument dedicated to aboriginal
veterans we were equals
on the battlefield
and today we will
again stand shoulder to shoulder
with our comrades and arms a few know
about the event and only a few dozen
attend tim lone is here every year he
served in the military for a decade and
worked on the truth and reconciliation
commission understanding
our
heroes that went off also include
indigenous peoples and died
you know and to unpack that history
is part of reconciliation for alone the
fact that this small ceremony is getting
more attention is a big step
[Music]
on this day the veterans who made it
home think of those who did not i feel
for the families of veterans who served
particularly those who are who didn't
come back madame simar
representing those families was this
year's silver cross mother jose simal
whose daughter corporal kerenblais died
in afghanistan in 2009
that pain and sense of loss shouldered
by one mother but shared by a nation
each year on this day
michael couture global news ottawa
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson was at the ceremony this
morning as well she joins me now
mercedes today is about remembering but
we can't ignore the fact the military
has had a difficult year the crisis in
leadership over misconduct allegations
the fact the taliban is now back in
charge in afghanistan what have you been
hearing from veterans today
well donna i spent this afternoon
talking to veterans and messaging with
them on things like instagram and
twitter and it is an incredibly
difficult year for a lot of our men and
women who served in uniform in fact a
number who i talked to some of whom
survived serious ied blasts in
afghanistan say that they just didn't
feel up to coming out they felt deeply
disappointed they feel disappointed by
the leadership in the canadian forces in
some cases when it comes to the sexual
misconduct scandal in other cases that
were compounding it's the withdrawal
from afghanistan these are people who
suffered through the internal dust that
you and i both experienced donna the
explosions the whale of the bag pipes on
the tarmac there as canadians who fell
were taken home and they really are
questioning what it was all for at this
point and having a very difficult time
so certainly this is a really
challenging remembrance day for a lot of
veterans who are feeling like what they
served for has all come into question
and it's important to note mercedes that
even though we're not involved in a war
right now there are thousands of
canadians in uniform serving in the
forces there are and our thoughts go out
to all those who are deployed they are
on navy deployments around the world
they are in iraq they are in latvia they
are in jamaica they are all over and we
don't hear about them that often but
that doesn't make their sacrifice any
less they are far from home today and
certainly our hearts go out to them and
our thanks for their service as they
continue to serve amid what experts say
are increasing threats to canadian
national security
all right mercedes stevenson at the
national war memorial in ottawa thanks
there were remembrance day ceremonies
all across canada today
in halifax home to one of the largest
canadian forces bases hundreds gathered
at the grand parade to honor the fallen
in edmonton local legions held scaled
back ceremonies this year after larger
events were cancelled because of the
pandemic
and in vancouver despite the public
being encouraged to watch virtually
people did join veterans and dignitaries
at victory square
ceremonies were also held around the
world today
this is london where the duchess of
cornwall led armistice day
commemorations at westminster abbey's
field of remembrance queen elizabeth did
not attend but buckingham palace says
she will take part in remembrance day
services at the cenotaph in london on
sunday the 95 year old monarch has been
under doctor's orders to rest
and in paris french president emmanuel
macron was joined by u.s vice president
kamala harris for their traditional
armistice day ceremony at the arc de
triomphe
on the border of poland and belarus this
was not a day to remember thousands of
migrants are stuck at the border in
freezing temperatures with no shelter
neighboring countries are now warning
the crisis could escalate into a
military conflict and belarus issued a
new threat today its president claims
he'll shut off a pipeline supplying
russian gas to europe if any new
sanctions are imposed on his country
crystal gomencing reports
the crisis is worsening along the border
between belarus and poland
food blankets and other life-saving
items are being handed out but support
for the migrants stranded in the
freezing cold is limited polish
officials won't let in the international
federation of the red cross and red
crescent we are completely unable to
reach all those people with critical
assistance
thousands from war-torn and economically
challenged countries made their way to
belarus after being told they could
cross into europe yusuf alhala made it
into poland but thought he'd die along
the way
freezing hungry and struggling with
injuries after allegedly being assaulted
by a belarusian soldier he kicked me in
the face
with
his foot
so i passed off for about a couple
minutes
broke my nose and broke a bone in here
and my eyes are sold like that
the european union accuses belarus of
luring migrants towards the border they
believe it's retaliation for sanctions
imposed on belarus for human rights
abuses belarus's president alexander
lakashenka denies the allegations on
thursday he raised the stakes
threatening to shut off natural gas
supplies to europe
we are heating europe and they are still
threatening us he said two russian gas
lines to europe pass through belarus
europe has been struggling with gas
supply issues and skyrocketing costs
since january but the block says it will
not be intimidated
more sanctions are now being considered
while the country's bordering belarus
warn of the growing risk of a military
clash
crystal gomanson global news
london
in glasgow negotiating teams are still
trying to agree on targets and rules on
how to cut carbon emissions at the u.n
climate summit the president of the
summit is calling on delegates from
almost 200 countries to step up their
efforts to reach a deal
we are not there yet on the most
critical issues
there is still a lot more work to be
done
and cop 26 is scheduled to close at the
end of tomorrow
so time is running out
alex sharma says the latest drafts show
significant progress but more effort is
needed on several key issues including
climate finance
[Applause]
and protesters in scotland are sounding
the alarm activists set up an air raid
siren calling on world leaders to do
more
it's one of the many demonstrations held
during the two-week cop 26 summit
the former chair of the truth and
reconciliation commission will
facilitate talks about compensation
aimed at reaching a settlement with the
federal government about indigenous
child welfare marie sinclair spent six
years documenting the legacy of
residential schools in canada he's a
former senator as well and was also
manitoba's first indigenous judge the
federal government has appealed a court
ruling upholding an order for it to pay
forty thousand dollars to indigenous
children who are unnecessarily taken
into the child welfare system the goal
of the talks with sinclair is to reach
an out of court settlement expected to
be worth billions by the end of this
year
accused killer kyle rittenhouse is
grilled in court coming up why the
murder trial is dividing americans
[Music]
in a courtroom in kenosha wisconsin a
remarkable criminal trial is unfolding
involving 18-year-old kyle rittenhouse
he's on trial for shooting three men
during street protests against racial
injustice rittenhouse claims he was
defending himself that night the
prosecution contends he was an armed
vigilante looking for infamy and as
jackson proskow reports his murder trial
is another sign of how divided america
has become
on the stand kyle rittenhouse sobbed
uncontrollably when asked about the
night he shot three men killing two of
them
that's right
rittenhouse insisted he acted in
self-defense arguing the men attacked
and chased him during protests in the
summer of 2020. i used deadly force
that you knew was going to kill
i didn't know if it was going to kill
them but i used the i used deadly force
to stop the threat that was attacking me
the trial centers around rittenhouse's
intent that august night
prosecutors argue the 17-year-old acted
as a vigilante showing up armed to
protests over the police shooting of
jacob blake the defense portrayed
written house as a scared kid who came
under assault by a mob
you never said a word to him other than
approach him with your gun out from
three feet away right yes
the case has become a lightning rod in
the culture wars rittenhouse has emerged
as a hero to many on the right his two
million dollar bail was paid through
donations don't get brazen with me judge
bruce schrader has also emerged as a
controversial figure ruling those killed
or injured could not be referred to as
victims the judge repeatedly scolded
prosecutors accusing them of improperly
trying to introduce prohibited testimony
when the judge says i'm excluding this
you just to take it upon yourself to put
it in because you think that you've
found a way around it come on that
prompted the defense to request a
mistrial with prejudice the judge
reserved his decision
instead the case will soon be in the
hands of a jury who will have to weigh
which version of events they believe
jackson prosko global news washington
south africa's last apartheid president
has died of cancer f.w de klerk was 85
years old the clerk oversaw the end of
the country's white minority rule a
system of legalized racism in 1990 he
ordered the release of nelson mandela
from prison after 27 years and he became
a key figure in the transition to
democracy de klerk and mandela went on
to share a nobel peace prize de klerk
was a controversial figure during a time
of brutal racial discrimination in south
africa and in a pre-recorded video
message released after his death the
clerk apologized for the pain and
indignity of apartheid
and lee merkel an award-winning
indigenous author poet and teacher has
died merkel received worldwide attention
for her lifelong advocacy for indigenous
equality in canada she mentored
up-and-coming indigenous writers won
several literary awards and was named to
the order of canada in 2018. merical a
member of the stolo nation recently
returned to bc where she grew up her son
says she was a fierce-hearted woman
she was 71 years old
sniper and savior ahead the story of one
of canada's most decorated indigenous
soldiers
this is the peace tower on parliament
hill tonight a virtual cascade of
thousands of poppies 100 years after the
poppy became a symbol of remembrance
each one represents one of canada's
fallen soldiers
there are many stories of bravery and
sacrifice by indigenous veterans but for
years they've been overlooked not given
the respect and recognition they deserve
francis pegamagabo's story is
extraordinary an ojibwe man he was a
sniper during the first world war and
though he proved himself an equal on the
battlefield he wasn't treated equally
when he got home
mike gerlay has his story
it's not easy to find the final resting
spot of one of the most decorated
indigenous soldiers in canadian history
francis pekin bagabo the sniper would
have likely wanted it that way
where there is no doubt is that he would
have found this quiet corner of the
wassoxing first nation near perry sound
peaceful free from the horrors of war
and politics of a country that all but
forgot what he did i would say his story
may have been sleeping it was a story
that was you know told um in
quiet
settings uh within his family or from
amongst community members he was known
as peggy to his fellow soldiers and a
terror to the enemy during some of the
most horrific battles of the first world
war some iprae passiondale he would
sneak into no man's land and wait his
patience led him to being credited with
378 kills and over 300 enemy captured
and after four years on the front lines
he was discharged with
68 898.68 in pay
he was happy to return to the shores of
georgian bay but like most indigenous
veterans he had hoped for a newfound
respect
instead it was more of the same poverty
and persecution
and the country he fought and bled for
still wouldn't grant him citizenship
they were trying to prove themselves
as equals
not to assimilate but to prove
themselves as equals as indigenous men
as indigenous canadians pekomagabo never
did stop fighting working tirelessly to
get more autonomy for band councils
until he died in 1952 he dedicated his
life fighting for indigenous rights of
course he returned a decorated military
hero but it was that work he did at
community levels at organizational
levels at uh you know being a warrior
for the rights for the language for the
culture of his people those are the
active contributions that i think we
most
know him for
okiewich
in was soxing today the name francis
pagamagabo is revered in both ojibwe and
english he was one of 39 canadian
soldiers awarded the military medal and
two bars for bravery
but it took until 2016 before he was
immortalized in bronze strong and
defiant on the shores of georgian bay
a hero given his due
mike trolley global news parry sound
ontario
no stone left alone next how younger
canadians connect with the stories of
fallen soldiers
there are many ways canadians can
reflect on those who served and
sacrificed for our country the no stone
left alone initiative is one of them
students place poppies on the headstones
of veterans connecting them to the
stories of the fallen it's a simple
gesture but an important and meaningful
one ross lord visited one special event
in the small town of middleton nova
scotia
[Music]
their faces are covered but their hearts
are open
students from nova scotia's middleton
regional high school paying tribute to
airmen who died during training missions
in the second world war at nearby cfb
greenwood the greenwood had
56 crashes but 60 65 men commonwealth
men were killed
and of
those men 24 are buried here for many of
these students like air cadet connor
obishon laying poppies at headstones
comes naturally albert j bartra royal
air force
my family has been primarily infantry
henley maurice albert william pilot
officer navigator royal air force
volunteer reserve
was just kind of thinking about like the
people that are under the earth and how
they
were so determined to just
protect our country to the point where
it cost them their life
[Music]
these tributes are coordinated by the no
stone left alone memorial foundation
started by this edmonton family they lay
poppies every year to honor family
members who served in the military
looking out at these vast amount of
headstones i wondered why is it only our
grandparents like why do we stop here
and we place it only on them ten years
later no stone left alone has grown into
a national symbol of gratitude pretty
soon word got out
and it continued to grow from there and
so this year
you know it warms my heart we have a
hundred communities even during this
covid half the people these days don't
even think about remembrance day anymore
they just think it's something that they
have to sit through an hour long and
just
they don't get to go on their phones but
i think it's nice to respect and honor
all the people who have sacrificed their
lives because we wouldn't be here today
if it wasn't for them
even a small gesture can have big
meaning just ask relatives of pilot
officer trevor pithock he was training
to be a navigator when his plane flew
into a fog shrouded hill in 1943. it's
sort of connects me in a in a funny way
i mean i don't know the students i don't
know who's doing it but it does it is
comforting to know that somebody is you
know he's being remembered and somebody
is is making that connection
venerable poppy incapable new hands
ross lord global news
middleton nova scotia
and that is global national for this
thursday remembrance day i'm donna
friesen we leave you with images from
the tomb of the unknown soldier in
ottawa where it's become a tradition for
people to come and lay their poppies
after the national ceremony
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
down
[Music]
you